hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
know some of you are probably worried
that I wasn't going to come back because
I lost my mind
shrimp naked and ran off to an island to
live by myself for the end of my days
but a few flaws with that plan I don't
want to go out in the ocean to live on
an island and number two I'm a bit
stronger than that generally speaking I
kind of have an idea of what oh I'm in
the shallows on it oh well hello
everybody I don't think I was supposed
to be here
ah [ __ ] eat it hey let me navigate some
[ __ ] here oh yeah I know things may
have gotten heated a little bit in the
last episode but that's okay I'm alright
and everyone else here is happy given
that there's no one up with them what
could I do
go [ __ ] goddamn it alright did I just
do that
I just Beach my goddamn big box Barry
son of an ass oh come on
ah [ __ ] okay hello hi why are we flying
now well apparently big box Barry is now
flying here we go okay well that was a
thing that happened oh this game is
welcoming me back with open arms
definitely happy to be here thank you
little sea creatures that I'm going to
eat and cook and in that order
but I am back in the game I feel better
and in this episode I know things are
gonna go better because I'm not going to
be hunting for anything now so I've got
lockers to make but I don't have the
necessary resources on my person to make
them
I'll make them when I get back down and
deliver big bucks Barry where he's
supposed to be is bay big bucks Barry
common thrill nobody bides be I'm just
baking a delivery honk honking honk honk
kids may oh boy they're not truck more
mate
I don't think big box bear gonna afford
more alimony okay so I'm going to make
my way back down into the depth because
if there isn't enough silver that I can
get here I know there's going to be
large deposits of it over there it's
just a matter of getting do it if I need
it and I'm pretty sure that I'm going to
need it but I'm not aren't sure if I
need it right now that's the defining
feature here so I'm gonna get back to my
base where I've got warp earth crawling
all over me but at least I have some
semblance of control over my life then
I'm going to build a modification
station oh hi honey
hey how's little old Jeremy is he good
that's not a name oh okay name is loser
I didn't know that I wasn't around I'm
speaking for big box Barry here but
somehow I feel like a parental figure
oddly enough I've got another problem
that's actually kind of significant here
I don't have much power left and
apparently the charging methods by which
to charge my big box Barry are no more
so I'll have to build a power cell
charger and see where that gets me but
in order to do that any materials so
back there we go know all that [ __ ]
re aside I'm headed back down into my
base where I'm going to feel safe and
home and then I'm going to build the
lockers and put some new names on the
wall and then I'm going to build the
modification station that I have so
desperately fought for you don't know
the trouble that I've gone to actually
you do you do know the troubles you know
exactly the troubles that I've gone
through and you know the lengths that I
would go to just in order to get a broad
application station so you know there's
not going to be anything that's going to
stop me from getting to the bottom of
subnautica because they put a castle
down there and they may not get into it
in this episode I may not get to it in
the next episode
but you've got a damn be sure that I'm
gonna get to it soon nothing's gonna
stand in my way and I'm getting back
down to bubble bud right about now oh
how I miss you little buddy
oh I'm so sorry for the abuse that you
have endured
I really feel bad I didn't mean for it
to go so poorly for you but god damn is
it dark in here let me just turn on my
floodlights cause holy [ __ ] oh it's much
better everything is illuminated out
especially the frickin douchebag is
floating around there try to warm into
plays I don't want to be warped no
you're in the dark I know you're down
there well so it seems like they made a
graphical update because everything
seems to be much clearer coffee [ __ ] I
know I could just give it in my mouth so
let's recap I need to make a
modification station thank you for the
coffee I need to make a modification
station and in order to do that I need a
lot of stuff I need a wiring kit and a
computer chip not actually all that much
so I look at my inventory I have nothing
bad but if I look at here I have hissing
I have copper go I feel ver hey things
are looking up for me
I've got silver and you know what that
bead I get to build lockers which have
nothing to do with the silver in the
output I'll be right back if you're here
become Adaro I'm crabby pitiable okay so
we got lapis angsty lazuli which i think
is a Steven universe reference who said
four hours and you still didn't cheat we
are so proud of you
or at least I am and I want to say thank
you very much
I'm proud of myself but not proud of
myself for not flailing like an idiot
and just giving up at the start of it
but I did it
that's the persistence that is the
markiplier way next up is swag bird who
said Marc didn't have an amazing
reaction to all the futuristic stuff in
the game instead he's crazy about the
fact that you can make coffee which is
really cool
entering I need a lot of coffee and then
there's lots of people which just stands
for a lot of you guys who said that
apparently there's a bug in the Rex and
the problem that I was seeing before
with absolutely nothing being there that
I could scan is actually a bug in the
game and in order to see those things I
would have had to restart the game and
then explore the space again well [ __ ]
me it was new update I didn't know about
it there was no way for me to find that
out so I got [ __ ] and that's really
cool I guess but c'est la vie that is
life and life is that so now I'm going
to make what I need to make and that is
the computer chip and a wiring kit I
need cable core sample okay I don't know
if it's down here I think I've asked
that very same question before but I'm
pretty sure that I might be able to find
it down here so ah but maybe I already
have it I should check that before I
just go wandering off into the ocean the
answer is yes I do have that so that's
good I have that on store which means
that I don't need to go any freaking
where to get whatever I need and that
means they're right here right now I get
to make me a modification station holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh brass key and with that the four-hour
journey has come to attend and now that
I have the modification station I can
make all of these various types of
upgrades including the pressure
compensator mk2 for the seamoth and the
pran which I'm more specifically going
to be using for the pran and the ultra
Cyclops reinforcement module and if I go
back to my Cyclops right now I've got a
whole mess of flat feeling it's and
titanium ingots and then I'm pretty sure
I got aluminum oxide crystals somewhere
here maybe haha I gotcha
I thought I wasn't going to get you but
then I gotcha
I got that that's good yeah if you're
wondering yes I may have lost a little
piece of my mind in the last episode but
that doesn't mean that I'm not dedicated
to going forward going deeper into the
ocean and having a great time among all
my dead friends ha ha ha anyway anyway
so now that I have that I can make these
upgrades but I gotta go into my uh I got
going to my big box bury for one second
whoa that was weird
I think they did do a graphical update
because something seems very do can I
please go in the master there we go
wolves ok but something seems just a
little bit different but I don't have
time to worry about that right now I
need to get all of the plasteel ingot
said I already have which is none I
thought I had some ad doesn't matter I'm
gonna take all the lithium that I got
which is a lot and then I'm gonna take
all the titanium ingots that I got which
is a lot I'm going to put the dead
batteries that I got in here someone
said I can't remember who I saw this in
passing but somebody said that I can
build a battery and or a power cell
charger in my big box bury and then use
that to charge its own power cells and
that'll create an endless loop of power
I don't know how nice that seems that
almost sounds like cheating to me so I'm
hesitant to do that however I am
desperate so we'll see how things turn
out I just don't want anything to do
with cheating I want to be very
dedicated and cheating includes
exploiting glitches that is cheating oh
I forgot something sorry I forgot I
forgot to actually pull the thing from
the things up hang on okay so I need
this crush depth is 500 meters that's
okay because I'm about to fix that
because I need to drink a lot of
plasteel ingot and then I need to take
those over to the the modification
station and make a whole lot of [ __ ]
do you the warper go nuts outside but I
don't care I'm safe in here with my
plasteel who needs friends when he got
Platt field please friends when he got a
modification station who needs friends
when he got a talking tree named Larry
that could keep you keep your company of
the coldest of nights anyway I'm looking
at what do people think I need one more
I need one more
I mean I'm eventually gonna need more
because I need to make the the pressure
compensators for my prod suits as well
but before I do that I need to make this
the ultra Cyclops reinforcement module
and with this I will be able to make
whatever I or go down as far as I need
to go with the Cyclops anyway I do need
to make it for the prawn suit before I'm
able to go anywhere because the Cyclops
can only go as far as the vehicle docked
within it so that means if the prawn
suit can only go to 900 meters the
Cyclops can't go any deeper than that
but for right now I'm going to count my
victory as they lay and stick this right
in this socket here
Oh 1,500 meters holy balls that's a lot
of meters so with that being said let me
just check see if there's an aluminum
oxide crystal in there because I need
dope Duff it is there boo boo boo boo
boy hey don't look at me here okay so I
got bat my Cyclops is now crushed down
to 1500 meters but the only problem is I
need to be able to make these other
upgrades and to do that I need a
computer chip and two aluminum oxide
crystals not just one I need - oh no oh
no that's fine I need a computer chip
and then I need aluminum oxide crystal I
believe I'm not sure I don't think I
have another aluminum oxide crystal I'm
pretty sure I do not have that yeah but
I do have I'm pretty sure I saw it yeah
I've got one more silver just one but
I've got it so that means uh hit the
table coral goddamn it back Hey okay so
what I got to do is I have to make I
have to make a run to get more table
coral and more if I'm gonna go I might
as well go all out because I believe I'm
gonna need to aluminum oxide crystals
and then two computer chips I best go
all-out for that I have the requisite oh
no I need more lithium I will need more
lithium I'll need three more lithium so
I got to go out and I got to make a run
that's no good but it's better than life
that I was living before which was a
goddamn nightmare so I'm gonna do that I
need to go gather materials but for
right now I'm sitting pretty I need to
power up these bad boys but I'm fitting
pretty pretty god I needed more power
here I need to get more I need to get a
lot more uranium before I do this what
am I going to do with you defeated
nuclear rods can I do anything with them
I think that just nuclear wait when you
can't really do much oh I could also I
could do that I could do that I can do
that I can do that I could get a
high-capacity pack down I could do that
okay I could do that I can do that okay
so all I need to do is I need unequip
that I need to put that there and then
BOOM I've got more oxygen less of a
problem for me
March is now 105 which is awfully nice I
believe someone said that I could
eventually make another one I also kind
of forgot about my see glide I forgot
the balance of thing that I could use
which would be awfully nice if I ever
needed to get out of my [ __ ] mr.
Pfister but that's never going to happen
because I'm going to be struggling to
survive so what I could do I don't have
silicon rubber that's okay
I'm not worried about let's just go out
there and get the materials we need we
need two more pieces of silver we need
aluminum oxide crystals and then we need
table the world so let's see what we
could do about that I'm going to save
because I feel like death is going to be
lurking grew out of a quota least I'm
down here down where it's better and
letter
hey it's weird I can see things a lot
better down here I don't know why but I
can a copper bunch of [ __ ] gold
bunch of [ __ ] copper bunch of
[ __ ] he's doing are you damaged
are you damaged are you dabbling why is
this guy dabbling when is when it makes
your fish to take damage hella doodoo oh
I got a bad feeling about this
hey oh really oh now now titanium sponge
down here huh I wonder if that's a
change that the developers made in
response to a great need such as my own
and it seems like finally that warper
has given me a break I say is the warp
or suddenly warps
out of nowhere okay so plenty of
aluminum oxide crystals down here so
that's not going to be a problem for me
I there's got to be on the lookout for
[ __ ] all right pull sit over here
I'm in need of an ample supply [ __ ]
Danny I'm copper they put they put whoa
hey okay they put these things by my
base because they knew that I needed it
I see what you're doing developers I see
what you're doing you did this for me
and I appreciate it
even though I may sound angry I'm very
grateful I'm so happy that that's
happening that's a big thing as coppers
only fat man a lot of gold what the [ __ ]
good is gold coal doesn't do anything
okay they're their way please stay away
I'm very dangerous Pat Dana where's the
silver I could duck and [ __ ] me
[Music]
okay all right then okay all right
cookie then what the [ __ ] is that well
that's a diamond deposit oh well I don't
need diamonds that's how that was gonna
be quartz Oh
worthless diamond [ __ ] come on I
don't think there's any silver deposit
study did I discover that that sounds
like familiar information that I
probably knew already grind that copper
net gold worthless gold and diamond
wherever you look golden diamonds I'm
and bra yeah okay all right oh okay
docking all right there's a bit of a
problem silver ore in the big chunks
only exists out in the dunes and the
dunes are directly north of me and
that's good because it's nearby but it's
also a bit tricky because I'm running
out of power so I need to find silver
ore to be able to make it how are so
charger and I need to have mr. Fisher
with me to go north to the dunes to be
able to harvest all that silver but also
my Cyclops is running out of power so
big box Barry may not make the return
trip so what I need to do is I need to
find a way to make a Power Cell charger
with a little bit of silver and then go
there get more silver make the rest of
the things that I need and then get down
dark below but here's another thing that
I've learned is in the dunes there's a
precursor cache in the dunes and if you
don't know what that means it means
there's a cache of technology that the
precursors who are the aliens that
warranting this planet that's left
behind somewhere in the dunes I don't
know where I haven't looked up
specifically is this information that
I've heard but more importantly that
cache is one of three now I may have
already found one of them on the
mountain but that means there's another
precursor cache with
cursor technology I've been told they
all need purple Keystone's to be able to
enter and if I recall I have an orange
artifact but not a purple artifact
I left my purple artifact back in my old
old base so what I need to do is I need
to figure out a way to one get silver to
be able to make a Power Cell charger
which I believe requires such a thing as
that yeah it needs the computer chip and
a wiring chip and glass and titanium not
too complicated if you have silver so I
need to go on a few errands but I
believe that my big box Barry is running
out of power as we speak I think I need
to turn the lights off after all but
either way I'm all out of time for this
episode I will be getting to this very
soon but my next step will take me to
the dunes and then back first back to my
old base that I first built and then
back to the dune dodge the Reaper
leviathans to try to find the precursor
artifact and also try to get as much
silver as I possibly can which requires
big box Barry which means that I've got
a busy day thank you everybody so much
for watching
there's your legs up so that doesn't
happen ah dark solitude creepy as hell
just the way I like it good thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]